[Music]
elaine is women with us in
wilmington delaware hi elaine how are
you
i'm good how are you guys doing great
what's up
um so in march i passed my occupational
therapy board so i have my master's in
occupational therapy however last year i
started a landscaping business
it's been full time so rather than
getting a therapy job
i went ahead and did the landscaping
full-time it's been a great source of
income
i have 12 000 left in debt and i'm
honestly just kind of burnt out so i was
trying to transition into my therapy job
now
so i have less landscaping jobs and i'm
kind of in a weird limbo where i have
accepted an outpatient pediatric job
which i'm very passionate about but it's
only one day a week and so that's not
enough
and i'm having a hard time finding
places that i'll take me for the other
four days
why did you leave the job you had before
you had another
job so i didn't i am a small business
owner so
i i couldn't grow anymore without hiring
someone and i didn't want to have to do
that because then you make less
i don't have a problem i don't have a
problem with that i'm just saying why'd
you shut it down before you had the new
job lined up
oh so i i did not shut it down okay um
i'm still doing it
but i have less jobs now than i did
so did you intentionally take fewer jobs
um
yes i did because i honestly was burned
out and my attention to detail was going
down and i didn't want to provide people
services to that mindset
um and i was ready to get started with
my professional career
for what i went to school with um
it's just the timing thing yeah right
um what did you say it was the timing
thing
you dropped you stepped off of one
income to no
income i just would i would have loved
for you to have had your
i mean i'd love for you have just gotten
uh you know your
your occupational therapy job and just
quit landscaping
right it's so getting credentialed
through insurance takes like a month so
actually a month ago i sent in some
applications and then i found out now
after i already dwindled down the job
that getting credentialed through
insurance takes some time
yeah um and i do have twelve thousand
dollars left of debt which i feel like
is eating me alive
um and i kind of feel like a bum having
eaten like
two days off a week um so this is kind
of just like a
i don't know i can't go anywhere i could
go to a really great restaurant
and apply and work there and make money
but you know who knows in a month i
might have to say i have to leave
you know i don't feel like morally right
to do so listen listen listen
you're cooked yeah okay
and i've sat with i can't even tell how
many students who have finished their
boards or finish the bar exam or finish
whatever and they're just cooked
and so where you find yourself is you
are fried but you did jump
off um you you chose to stop paying
attention to detail because you got
tired right it's not something that
happened to you it's something that you
chose to do
you are just zonked okay and
what happens when you get zonked to
sometimes you start catastrophizing and
start creating situations that then you
try to solve that haven't even happened
yet
so what i'd love to see you do is go
find somebody in your community you can
talk to just go talk to a counselor once
or twice
just go find some go out with your
friends have people over to your house i
want you to
be human again okay you've been a robot
attacking tasks for a long time yeah
you've been in fight or flight for years
okay you're gonna have to take some more
lawn jobs
and do some more landscaping jobs until
you land a full-time job and then here's
what you do
you call your landscape clients and say
i'm getting out of this and so here's
your two-week notice
and then you move on right and they will
find somebody
else but you have overthought this and
overspun this because
your body's cooked and you just need to
start laughing again
invite some friends over to your house
again you gotta make some money so
you're gonna have to pick up some more
jobs again
if you just can't start that lawnmower
one more time then go get a job at a
restaurant i just don't know why you
wouldn't just do it for another five or
six months
getting your boards it's fr you thought
you were gonna ride into a new job as
soon as you pass that test we're gonna
start on monday
and then you realize are you freaking
kidding me there's more hurdles
yes there's more hurdles and so now
you're right back in it
take some more jobs make some more money
but start being a person
make the transition by christmas yeah
but don't make it by tuesday don't make
it by tuesday you're so close honey
you're so close and you're so strong and
you've made it you're going to be good
but you're not quite there yet okay so
maybe make
like christmas my headline yourself i
don't care i just made that up
i just made that up tired of the
landscaping yeah you're taught
you're tired but you're so close this is
a terrible example and i wish i had
another one off top of my head but this
is live radio
you know when you're in a long car ride
and you got to pull over because you got
to go
and then it feels right when you get to
the gas station all of a sudden it
becomes a super emergency
right that's where you're at that's
where you feel you just gotta hang in
there
okay don't go in the car wait till you
get inside okay
[Laughter]
maybe the the worst live radio analogy i
think it
probably qualifies as one of the worst
ever
hey i know you're fried i want you to
have some people over this week you'll
watch a movie you get some pizza it's a
glass of wine y'all
laugh but start re-engaging humanity
again
you're strong enough to hang on to do
the transition
wisely instead of this gap that you left
between
the incomes which is now scaring you
more than the burnout scared you
does that make sense i have no reason to
stress financially i
just got married in june and you know
i'm
we're everything's great so yeah your
stress is not about math
it's not about math your stress is that
your body has been in fight or flight
it's been on
cortisol and adrenaline for years and it
finally just said enough
you've been cranking through these tasks
and it's just you you've
you've been in in a machine
in a good way but very robotic but but
uh
it got you through there and you can go
you can go from here
so you you got the stuff it takes you're
just going to have to make this
transition a little more gentle
because it's driving you nuts yeah